[laughter]
>>Dan: Hello.
All right, Ian.
Fantastic.
And welcome to another episode of The Friday
Games Review.
I, as always, am Dan Galpin.
And with me, we have Daniel Pham.
>>Daniel: Hey, guys.
How are you doing?
>>Dan: And today, we're going to be looking
at Asian RPGs.
They're both Japanese and Korean RPGs, which
have become very, very popular in Google Play.
And here on the producer cam, we have Ian
Ni-Lewis, who is going to be not only chiming
in with important and incisive comment, but
also pouring the beers for us today.
>>Ian: Absolutely.
So, yeah.
Let me go ahead and take care of my most important
duty right now.
[clink]
Today, we are pouring something that I think
our resident foreigner should probably name
for us.
This is a--.
>>Dan: We're talking about Reto here.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Dan: Who we actually haven't seen yet.
Let's make that clear for the audience.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Reto: Ale des Deux.
>>Ian: Very good.
OK.
Actually brewed right here in the Valley.
San Jose, California, actually.
Home of me and also hobos who get hacked apart
with samurai swords.
That was our news story of the week.
>>Dan: It's to have to keep this show topical.
>>Ian: Yeah.
Anyway, [ indistinct ] pour this.
>>Dan: That's right.
>>Ian: And the sharpest one.
>>Dan: It could be really dangerous if I was
wearing this hat near the San Jose Sharks.
>>Ian: All right.
And we'll--.
>>Dan: By the way, a big shout-out to Scout,
who's an APM here who loaned me this hat for
the show.
We are trying to figure out what would be
the proper show to wear a giant red squid
hat for.
And somehow, hey, wow.
That's nice.
And somehow, this one won the straw.
So today, we're--.
>>Daniel: It's a great hat.
>>Dan: It is.
It is a good, it is a good hat.
>>Daniel: I love it.
>>Dan: Oh, yes, please.
Here, we get the compostable glasses for me
rather than the fabulous Oktoberfest glass.
That is a fantastic Google Oktoberfest glass.
People should see this, yeah.
There we are.
So, it's great to have Daniel aboard here.
And--.
>>Daniel: Great to be here.
>>Dan: Thank you.
Thank you.
And we've had a lot of fun playing the games
this week.
One thing about these Asian RPGs in general
is it takes a long time to actually get into
the game.
And--.
>>Daniel: Yeah, I mean, in just the 40 hours
I've had or--
[Dan laughs]
so to playing, I really couldn't get a really
in-depth look at any one title.
It requires hundreds and hundreds of hours
just to get it right.
>>Dan: The best part, Final Fantasy Three
actually, which is one of the ones we're looking
today, shipped on Google Play.
And there were a bunch of reviews that said
the game was only a couple of hours long.
And that is because a couple of people only
played through the intro.
And after the intro, it actually plays the
credits and then it goes on to play the other
30 hours of game play or so.
>>Daniel: Yes.
>>Dan: So, these are really deep, intensive
games.
Another thing that's interesting about all
of these games, and we're only gonna be looking
at four today, all four of these games are
originally ports from other platforms.
So, a lot of the experience on Android is
colored by how deep the port operation actually
got.
And so, Final Fantasy Three, I believe, came
over from the DS.
The rest of them from the PlayStation portable.
And it's possible is the only four, I don't
know if it actually appeared on anything else.
So, that one, it's just the style, certainly,
of that game.
And we also have really three distinct styles
of game play here.
We have Final Fantasy Three, which is a turn-based
fighting game, but without significant deep
tactics.
We have Spectral Souls, which is a deeply
tactical turn-based fighting game.
And then we have arcade-style role playing
games, which are Inotia Three and Zenonia
Four.
So we really do have quite a variety of game
play all under the general umbrella of Asian
RPGs.
And there's a lot of things that are very
specific to this style of game play.
Deep story is what drives the game.
There's certainly RPG elements and they vary
depending on the game.
We also have different monetization strategies
across these four games.
So, we can talk a little bit about what the
impact of the specific porting that was done
as well as a little bit of the game playing
styles itself.
So, let's start off with the game we played
the most, which is Final Fantasy Three.
I think both Daniel and I are old Square fans.
>>Daniel: Yeah, definitely.
>>Dan: Why don't, I'll bring this up.
And I'd like Daniel to chime in on this one.
>>Daniel: Sure.
>>Dan: So, what's interesting about this game
is they actually are supporting two different
modes of save game within the game.
You can actually quick save, which uses a
save state.
And you can do that anywhere within the game.
But it also supports what was traditionally
the game with save slots.
So, you've got continue, new game, and load
game.
Continue just goes into the last quick save.
One thing to note in this game, if you don't
actually save slots, you actually, when you
die, you die.
So, it is actually important to use the old
school save game system.
>>Daniel: Definitely.
I made that mistake the first time playing
through this game.
And it was a little bit annoying, but--.
>>Dan: It's a little bit of a shock to a modern
game.
We're not used to a game where we actually
are killed off after ten hours of game play
and suddenly have to start over.
>>Daniel: Yeah.
>>Dan: And--.
>>Daniel: Instantly reminded me of Battletoads.
That's a game for another day.
>>Dan: Exactly.
So, another thing you'll notice is that we're
looking here at the typical screen.
And we're slightly covering the only controls
that are there.
You'll see there aren't actually a significant
number of controls on the screen.
The controls are actually activated when we
touch the screen.
And very much this style of game play.
This, again, is a remake of the original Final
Fantasy Three, which showed up on the eight-bit
Nintendo Entertainment System, or Famicom.
And, in fact, I don't think it ever shipped
in the United States other than through some
very creative people who produced English
translations of this.
And it wasn't really until we got into the
later Final Fantasy games that we actually
started numbering them appropriately in the
US.
I could be wrong, but that's my recollection
here.
So, the game itself is pretty straight-forward.
We're inside of a town right now.
We can exit the town.
And in Final Fantasy true epicness, we actually
have a flying machine that we can use to fly
around the world map.
This, by the way, is the intro part of the
game, just to let you know.
This is the first section of the game where
we actually have to free this town where everyone
has been turned into ghosts from the clutches
of this djinn.
And we have to get some Mithril rings and
all sorts of fun stuff like that.
And really, they've done a marvelous job with
this remake from the DS.
>>Ian: I'm sorry.
Did you say "clutches of gin?"
>>Dan: Of a, [laughs].
Yes, of a D-J-I-N-N.
OK.
>>Ian: Oh.
Suddenly I lost interest.
Carry on.
>>Dan: OK.
So, we lost our viewers right there.
They thought we were talking about alcohol
for a moment there.
So, there's beautiful little in-game cut scenes.
And it's interesting.
They've actually chosen, you may not be able
to tell this from looking at the graphics
that run through the game, but they've actually
chosen to keep the game unfiltered for the
most part.
So, you'll see that the graphics look, instead
of looking blurry, they look intentionally
blocky.
>>Daniel: Yeah.
That was really nice.
A nice touch by them.
And back in the cut scenes, I was really impressed
by that.
I didn't expect something like that to come
out of an Android game.
But maybe I just had poor experiences playing
Android games in general.
>>Dan: Exact.
We need to get you playing more Android games,
it's clear.
Yeah.
It's really beautifully done.
They've also done a very good job of integrating
most of the Android features.
Probably the only really confusing thing is,
again, the old school elements of the game,
which we definitely have to get used to if
you haven't played this sort of game in a
while.
>>Daniel: Yeah.
For some of our younger viewers, they may
not be familiar with this style of, that this
game is shown in.
>>Dan: Absolutely.
And, so talk about the things that were done,
they're done well.
One of the things I really enjoyed is that
even though the game has old school, unfiltered
graphics, if you look at the font, you can
see the font is rendered at full resolution,
independently of the game.
And that makes the game feel so much better
because your eyes aren't trying to focus on
a font that's blurry or filtered.
And it's also not trying to, you're not looking
at something that's really, really low resolution.
And it really fits in quite well with the
game--even with the old school graphics.
You can see that both on the font there in
the text as well as on the map and menu icons,
which we're covering up with our current view
here in the corner.
So, there are some things that are interesting
about this.
One is that we hit the back key.
We get close application, OK?
First of all, it's a little jarring because
we actually end up getting a dialogue that
is a system dialogue rather than our own.
It's also a dialogue that's not a Holo-style
dialogue So, we're kind of thrown out there.
You can see we actually have, at the bottom
of the screen, a vestigial menu key that doesn't
do anything.
I touch it.
It doesn't do anything.
And we also have the zoom button over here,
which allows us to stretch or zoom in to make
it as if we were playing this on an old school
device.
So, all of this could easily be corrected,
of course, by simply targeting a more recent
version in terms of the menu and the zoom.
And as far as the back key is concerned, in
this case, it really just makes sense to go
back to the main menu since you can continue.
This would be a perfect opportunity to quick
save, go back to the main menu.
It would be much, much less jarring for the
user.
Now, if you quick save within the game, you'll
note it's a little confusing, too.
You click the quick save button, say "Yes,
perform quick save."
And it does immediately then kick you off
of the game and take you back to the title
screen.
>>Daniel: Yes, yeah.
>>Dan: And quick save is really what it does
when you exit the game in the middle of playing
it.
So, by doing that, you go back.
This is probably, this is what the default
behavior should be, probably should pop up
something, let you know that you're quick
saving and then take you back to the title
screen when you hit the back key.
It should give a bit more warning.
Yeah, I mean, again, quick saving, because
it's such a simple thing to quick save, in
this case for the end user and it's very easy.
It's really straight-forward.
You just hit continue.
It can be done with really, really minimal
prompting.
So, there's a lot of, there's a lot of work
that goes in to prompt the user to try to
help the user out.
The reality is what mostly what they wanna
do is just immediately quick save when they
hit that back key, similar to what happens
when you hit the home key.
And then the game is closed.
It actually will quick save for you if you're
in the middle of game play.
So, that's something I would definitely look
at in terms of being able to just interact
that much more smoothly with Android.
Another thing is I'll go here back to--.
So, now I have right now exited.
I'm going back to the main screen here, which
is, once again, as a general rule, you wanna
be able to continue past all of these things
here at the beginning.
It's just, you hit the back key here, close
application.
It's not really necessary if you're on the
title screen.
So, this is just something I would definitely
like to see them clean up.
And again, I think everything else when we
get here is, in this game, is really just
is vestigial from its original origins.
You have a limited number of save slots.
You have, and the game really is about knowing
when to save, making sure you have saved at
appropriate times.
And it's very traditional.
Your object is not to complete the story,
but it's also to avoid death.
>>Daniel: Yes.
>>Dan: Death is very painful in this game
and can cause you hours and hours and hours
of having to redo things.
And interestingly, you can't quick save at
any time, but quick saves don't really help
you out other than to save your progress because
you can only have one slot and the game deletes
the quick save slot when you die.
>>Daniel: Yes.
>>Dan: So again, it's very, very much about
juggling those internal slots.
I think it's a little bit confusing to a user
of the game that you have to juggle these
kind of two independent mechanisms.
>>Daniel: I was angry.
>>Dan: But it is really good that they have
that and it definitely makes it a mobile and
complete title.
The other game that I think is really interesting
that's close to the same, closest to the same
genre is Spectral Souls.
And Spectral Souls is an epic and huge, huge
game.
Thank you for changing the, yes.
>>Ian: Yeah.
I also have to mention that the developers
of Spectral Souls are probably my favorite
developers ever.
So, hey Carlo and that other dude that I can't
remember who's buddies with Carlo.
[Dan laughs]
You had, you gave us the most epic night of
drinking at the Marriott Skybar ever.
>>Dan: Who is us, by the way?
I was not there.
>>Ian: No.
>>Daniel: Neither was I. I wasn't there either.
>>Ian: Well, so it's true that Dan Pham was
not there.
Dan Galpin left early--
>>Dan: Yes.
>>Ian: before we found the stuff--.
>>Dan: Before the epic stuff happened.
Yeah, exactly.
>>Ian: Android in the corner that was six
feet tall and the CEO of SpryFox put it on
and went dancing around the bar.
That was a good night.
>>Daniel: And that was a little bit of an
edited version from what I heard earlier.
>>Dan: Yeah, absolutely.
That was good, that was good editing for our
family viewers.
So, Spectral Souls.
Let's get back to the game.
But we've had, the good thing is that we've
had a long relationship with these developers.
They've done a really, really good job of
taking a really epic game from the PlayStation
portable and bringing it here.
But you do see a lot of vestiges of what they
had to do.
One of them is if you look at the on-screen
controls here, you can see that you have a
constant on-screen hub of arrow keys.
And the arrow keys are actually fairly far
apart here on this tablet, if you look here
on what is I believe your, are you the left-hand
side of the screen?
I guess we're seeing a mirror here.
So, and so, you'll see they're actually fairly
far apart.
And you'd actually want those to be closer
together on a tablet of this screen size.
But on a phone, they're in about the right,
they're about the right size and orientation.
The rest of the buttons are actually pretty
good on the tablet, although you do have to
reach fairly far if you're actually trying
to control it with two hands to get to the
start button there in the center.
And then you have buttons that are anonymously
labeled "A," "B," "C," and "D," with no indication
of what their function might be.
"B" normally goes back.
>>Daniel: It's part of the mystery, Dan.
>>Dan: It is part of the mystery of, and so
part of your job in this, and I think if you're
this kind of gamer who enjoys those kinds
of games, is to try to puzzle out how the
user interface works as you're playing the
game.
Also, the game is very, very deep.
If you're used to Final Fantasy levels of
combat, this is much more like Final Fantasy
tactics, where there really is a lot of tactical
element to the combat itself.
The goal is to chain attacks in order to inflict
maximum damage.
And also, the terrain is very, very important.
There actually are hills--
>>Daniel: Yeah.
>>Dan: in the terrain and elevation.
And you actually have to move strategically
to sometimes cut off other player, other characters
sometimes to surround them properly so you
can chain attacks appropriately.
So, there is really a lot of strategy in this
game.
We're very, very early in this game, in this
scene here.
Some little notes.
Again, we're just coming back to it.
It's PlayStation portable origins, we do see
this incredibly low res font here that they've
chosen to--.
You also notice they've chosen to filter all
of their graphics.
The HUD isn't very high res.
It's very, very nice by the way.
All the elements they've added are definitely
there.
But in terms of, it is a little bit jarring
to have that in there in terms of--.
It would be great if they could figure out
a way of actually modifying the engine to
support some higher res text, or perhaps just
not filtering the text.
In this particular case, I think the filtering
is actually diminishing from the impact of
the text within the game.
And really, the only other comments I have
are comments about what, about the HUD and
just making the game a little bit cleaner
in terms of being able to have people understand
the controls.
Once you realize that you're playing a game
that includes a set of random buttons and
you have to figure out what they do in different
situations.
And the game is consistent with how they're
used, 'cause, of course, it was consistent
on the original game.
I think you do figure that out.
You can see like, all the screens they have
in the game are all very, very simple, nondescript.
>>Daniel: Yeah.
>>Dan: Again, a nice use.
You're actually seeing, this is a dialogue
Hitting the back key again doesn't do anything.
It should.
So, these are just little, when you're porting
these games, it's always tricky to figure
out what to do in each one of these situations.
And if we were gonna look at this today in
terms of featuring, they would definitely
say, "Hey, the back key should be popping
back out of that pod screen or move them back
to the main screen of the game rather than
stopping there."
But in general, it's, for what it is, it's
a very good game.
Also, note that this game has an enormous,
enormous, enormous secondary download.
And this game was one of the first enormous
games to ship.
>>Daniel: Yeah.
So, if you're downloading this game, plan
to go get a cup of coffee, take a bathroom
break, watch a TV show, something along those
lines before you can actually play it.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: As I recall, you guys, can't you like
play Pong while you're downloading this?
>>Dan: Yes, yes.
I'll say it.
One of the cool things the developers have
done is you actually--
>>Ian: I thought that was awesome.
>>Dan: They implemented Pong.
Now, unfortunately, it's, as far as I can
tell, it's impossible to win their game of
Pong.
You can play it--
>>Daniel: Yes.
>>Dan: during the download.
And that brought back some great memories
as well.
So, yeah.
And it's very cool.
It actually gives you progress.
I think it does win for the coolest downloader
on Android.
>>Daniel: Yeah, by far.
>>Ian: All right.
I just wanna also point out to you guys that
we have just regained the amount of viewers
that we lost while I was telling my Carlo
Perconti getting drunk at the Marriott story.
[Dan laughs]
So, I just thought I'd break in to see if
my face on the TV is actually gonna lose us
four or five more viewers.
>>Dan: I think people are just interested,
I think people are in suspense as to whether
or not this squid hat is actually gonna fall
off my head at some point during--.
>>Daniel: It's sliding backwards a little
bit.
>>Dan: It's, this is a very challenging hat
to wear.
>>Reto: I don't think people are waiting to
see whether it falls off.
They're waiting to see if it starts to become
self-animated.
>>Dan: Oh, that's possible.
Yeah.
It could become self-aware during the show.
>>Ian: I will say this.
I've been watching the YouTube livestream.
And actually, if you guys are watching on
YouTube Live, there is a livestream comments
where I'm like pathetically typing, "Hey,
dude.
Anybody there?
How about some questions and stuff like that?"
[Dan laughs]
I feel a little bad about myself actually.
But I would say out of about 20 comments,
about 12 of them are praising Dan's hat.
>>Dan: Is that right?
Yeah.
>>Ian: The squid hat is a huge winner.
>>Dan: All right.
>>Ian: On the other hand, according to our
G plus stream, the Android beanie, clear loser.
>>Dan: Really?
People did not like the Android beanie.
>>Ian: I know.
They did not.
>>Dan: OK.
>>Ian: But it's because they felt that it
was a poor quality Android beanie and you
could do better, Dan.
>>Dan: All right.
There we are.
>>Ian: Back to our regularly scheduled program.
>>Daniel: Goal for next week?
Get an even better hat.
>>Dan: Better beanies.
So, yeah.
I don't really have that much more to say
about Spectral Souls because I only played
it for about four hours.
And it really takes a long time to get farther
into the games.
>>Daniel: Yeah.
>>Dan: So, I can only assume the story stays
engrossing and fun as it certainly was from
the start.
So that gets us through, I think, the two
that I would describe as Japanese RPGs that
are in this set.
And now we also have two Korean RPGs as well.
>>Daniel: And the two I enjoyed a little bit
more than the first two.
>>Dan: So, you really?
>>Daniel: Yeah.
Actually, I did.
I'm more of a fan of the arcade-style games.
I have ADHD.
It's not--.
I don't actually have ADHD but--.
>>Dan: I feel like we should have some music
here.
As you now tell us stories how this has impacted
your life.
Sorry.
Go on.
>>Daniel: Let me rephrase.
I have a short attention span and these games
manage to keep my attention a whole lot better
then the first two have.
>>Dan: Yeah.
And we've got two examples in this genre.
We have Inotia3 which is from Com2uS.
And this game was really, I think it really
set the bar high for Korean RPGs coming to
Android.
It was really the first one that I was excited
about.
And yes, [indistinct].
But good that it didn't force me to join there
to do that as a general rule.
So we can continue the game.
I'm a level four Barbarian.
For anyone who's played the game knows that
I haven't played that far on this tablet.
So, some general notes here.
And we've actually talked about Inotia in
previous episodes.
I don't need to go over this in great detail.
Obviously, on the tablet, the HUD is huge.
It's enormous and it's low res.
And these, as you're controlling the character,
you can see I really do have to move my finger
quite a long way across the tablet in order
to actually use this controller that is here
on the left-hand side.
Also, we're seeing, once again, evident that
this game was a port.
As you know, the graphics are very, very low
resolution for modern devices.
>>Daniel: Yeah.
>>Dan: Now, that doesn't really take away
from the charm of the game very much.
And I certainly would not want them to not
bring this game to Android just because of
that.
I think they've done a really, really nice
job with the original pixel art on the game.
And it's really quite charming.
The basic game is controlled using, essentially,
a single button control with a bunch of pop-up
buttons that have different actions.
And this is just also very, very, really very
straight-forward--very intuitive.
You can slash things with your action button.
And there's also a series of action controls.
The game involves a lot of repetitive actions.
So, ads are, as you can see, placed into the
game with this is I believe an ad-supported
game only.
>>Reto: Dan, if you want for people to be
able to see the controls, if you actually
take the Galaxy Nexus out of that plastic
container and put the tablet in there, then
people will be able to see your hands as well.
>>Dan: That's a good point.
All right.
So, 'cause we can't actually--.
>>Ian: Or just hold it--.
Well, if you use preset one, you can actually
hold it.
>>Reto: Dan's had made preset one a little
tricky.
>>Dan: We should, yeah.
Show us preset one, just to--.
>>Reto: Sure.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: All the presets, 'cause they're awesome.
>>Reto: The cable has come loose, so you'll
wanna fix that.
>>Dan: Ah, yes.
That's a good point.
>>Reto: There you go.
See?
How beautiful is that?
>>Dan: That is glorious.
All right.
Fabulous.
So, you can actually see the HUD and how long
it, the amount of distance I do actually have
to move my fingers across to change the direction.
So we definitely wanna see, the fact that
this is a large screen device being taken
advantage of.
I'd like to see the HUD be higher resolution
as well.
Generally, fonts in the game be higher resolution
And, 'cause they do feel blurry on this device.
But the controls are fun.
You actually have an option of using these
special attacks here as we kill off deer.
>>Daniel: I really like the control mechanism.
I can mash all day long on a game like this
and get results.
But you're right that the HUD size does make
it a little difficult to smash all the buttons
at the same time.
>>Dan: Absolutely.
[laughs] That's right.
>>Daniel: It's something, I used to love doing
StreetFire, too.
Just button mash all day.
>>Dan: But again, very, very, very similar
in style.
In buildings, we have this sort of different
building view, which makes this building--.
I mean, from the outside this building looks
actually quite small.
From the inside, the building's enormous.
[Daniel laughs]
And that's also, I would say, something that,
I didn't even notice the fusion machine.
That's cool.
This is just how you synthesize things.
Also notice, hitting the back key here does
not pull me out of what is very obviously
a dialogue in the game.
We have an on-screen back control.
So, there about a billion reasons that the
Android market, sorry, Google Play.
I should start to drink every time I say Android
Market.
Google Play team.
>>Daniel: I'll drink for you.
>>Dan: Thank you.
The Google Play team would have lots to say
about this before featuring it.
But it is really a very well done game in
this genre.
But another thing the game does do is, and
one of the first quests in the game--there
are lots of quests is that's how the game
is broken up--is to actually send you back
to Google Play to rate the game.
And if you rate the game high--.
>>Daniel: Yeah.
>>Dan: If you actually go and take that quest,
it pops up Google Play and then it gives you
some special potions.
And as we probably mentioned before, that
is actually against the policy of Google Play.
>>Daniel: It made me a little bit sad.
>>Dan: It did.
It did.
At least they're not asking you for a five-star
rating, but they are asking you to rate the
game in return for giving you something within
the game.
>>Daniel: Yeah.
>>Dan: As a general rule, we love games and
encourage people to review.
Just try not to incentivize them other than
saying, "Yes.
If you liked our game, review us."
>>Daniel: And if I am gonna review a game,
I want a little bit better of an incentive
than just some potions.
[Dan laughs]
Maybe like a cool sword or something.
>>Dan: Someone can contact Daniel offline
for incentives, for rating incentives.
>>Daniel: Yeah, please.
Yeah, please.
Send me a message online.
Like, make sure it's at least a sword or some
cool armor or something, custom graphics.
>>Dan: [laughs] Again, I'm gonna pull it off
of here 'cause it's too hard to keep HDMI
actually going.
So, we're not going to able to use that camera
anymore.
But the game really is deep.
It has quite a lot going for it.
So, the final game that we're actually looking
at--we're going through these pretty quickly
here--is from our friends over at GameVille.
And--.
>>Daniel: We're gonna do Zenonia.
Is that correct?
>>Dan: This is Zenonia Four.
And Return of the Legend.
And we, I was excited about this game for
a lot of reasons.
One of it is that it's just beautiful, beautiful
pixel art.
>>Daniel: Yeah, I loved it.
I loved it.
The art was amazing.
Everything's high resolution.
The controls are really easy.
It's, I hate to say this, but it's almost
a more polished version of the Com2uS game.
>>Dan: Yeah, it is definitely, it is definitely
a later game.
You can see that I've got, it actually, it
makes use of vibration when I'm doing this.
And actually, I'm pretty far in the game here.
We're already several hours in the game.
I'm level six.
[laughs] And again, the game is very high
resolution.
I would still like to see higher res fonts.
It's still a bit blurry.
And one of the nice things about this game
is that you'll notice actually, and I should've
mentioned that before when talking about Inotia3,
that you actually do see artifacts due to
basically filtering where it's actually blurring
stuff that's outside of the current texture
of the game.
>>Daniel: Yeah.
Yeah.
That's right.
>>Dan: So you see like, little pixels, stray
pixels here and there.
You don't see any of that in this game.
It's just, it looked beautiful at this resolution.
>>Daniel: Another thing I wanna note is that
this game and the last game, you can skip
through a lot of the cut scenes.
So, if you're not a fan of story driven games
and you wanna skip right to the action, you
can definitely do that.
>>Dan: Another is if you have a short attention
span, this is the game for you.
>>Daniel: That's why I love these games.
That's why I love them.
Get right to the action.
>>Dan: Exactly.
>>Daniel: Skip all the stuff.
>>Dan: Now, for me, this, I will say that
from a game play perspective, there was a
little bit too much of I walk off a screen
and I walk back on it.
Oh, look.
All the monsters are back.
And I know that's an important part of the
element of this sort of game and it certainly
gives you the unlimited ability to keep leveling
up, but I did find it a little frustrating.
Now, is there a better way to use potions,
by the way, then going to your inventory here
and actually picking 'use potion'?
>>Daniel: I couldn't find it.
>>Dan: OK.
I was like, "Really?
That's how I have to do this?"
But maybe if someone, there is this plus button
here, but it doesn't seem to help.
>>Daniel: Yeah.
>>Dan: So, there, I was really hoping for
something better within the HUD to say, "Hey,
I really wanna use a potion 'cause I'm almost
dead."
>>Daniel: Yes.
>>Dan: And there was no way to get that.
>>Daniel: That was one of my complaints as
well that if you're in the middle of a five-monster
fight and you wanna use a potion, it's annoying
to have to go into the menu screen.
>>Dan: It is jarring.
And again though, big action button.
I think it's interesting to look at this and
compare this against what we saw in Final
Fantasy Three, which had really, really minimal
displaying controls on screen.
And this, we have lots and lots of stuff all
over the screen.
And it's, they're both very effective.
I think this, in some ways, is more intuitive,
but I really like the minimalist approach.
And once you've actually played the game for
just a few minutes, you figure out fairly
quickly.
One thing we have this many buttons on the
screen, even though it is somewhat intuitive
buttons on the screen, it's like when you
have this many buttons, it starts to get tricky
what you're actually doing.
>>Ian: So, I had a question for you, Dan.
First, based on some things that we're seeing
on the YouTube livestream.
>>Dan: Yes.
>>Ian: How are the controls on this compared
to Inotia?
>>Dan: I think they're a little easier.
The controls are a little closer together.
So, I find it's a little easier on a tablet.
They still have the same basic problem, though,
that they aren't scaling the signs of the
D-pad for the tablet, which I would like to
see.
>>Ian: So, they really should be scaling that.
And would you like to explain to our developers
the best way to do that?
>>Dan: Sure.
So, what we're talking about here is this
device is a large screen device which has
a screen resolution of--.
>>Daniel: NDPI.
>>Dan: Sorry, a screen, yeah, density of what
we call NDPI, which is about 150 pixels per
inch.
And so, what we were trying to do whenever
we size one of these controls, we're actually
looking to size them based approximately on
the size of your finger.
In this case, we're trying to look at what
is a comfortable motion.
The good news about this particular HUD is
it really is a good compromise between form
and function.
It works very, it works well enough because
the controls are all placed close to the edge
on both sides.
So, it's actually very, very easy to reach
all of the controls within the game.
And so, it's not, it's a little bit better
than what's going on with Inotia, which has
controls that are farther out and much, much
better than what was going on with Spectral
Souls where you had controls just spread across
the whole screen.
>>Daniel: Yeah, yeah.
>>Dan: Even though Spectral Souls had these
very, very beautiful high res controls, which
I really, really liked, having them spread
across the screen made things challenging.
Because they put the buttons in the corners,
they actually work fairly well on a tablet.
And you can actually see.
Oh, is the cable out again?
Oh, sorry guys.
It's again--.
>>Ian: When Reto was making that motion, it
wasn't dirty.
It meant, "Put the cable back in, Dan."
>>Dan: Right.
Right.
Exactly.
>>Ian: So, I also have one more question and
it's just based on what I'm seeing from the
screen shots here.
Keep in mind that I haven't actually played
this game, but as far as I can tell, on the
screen when you're in the action, you are
apparently a fairly young child wearing a
cowboy hat and carrying a gigantic gun.
>>Dan: Yes.
>>Ian: But in the cut scenes, or when you're
actually talking to somebody, you're apparently
a cross between Billy Idol and Britney Spears.
So, can you explain that?
>>Dan: Well, it's interesting that you mention
that.
Actually, in the game story line, it is actually
mentioned that the character is surprised
that he looks like a child.
And he's actually been brought back in time.
So, they do actually try to justify the childlike
experience.
However, they are talking about the somewhat
older child that appears in the cut scenes
rather than the very young child.
Now, this kind of squashed art style is hallmark
of both Japanese and Korean role playing games.
And so, having the character run around in
this wide-eyed childlike form is definitely
a signature element of these games.
And I think a lot of the reason is the characters
are small.
They want to differentiate them very, very
easily.
And if they actually tried to make them look
more adult, there's fewer pixels to draw eyes,
fewer pixels to draw facial features.
And so, it became easier in these games to
differentiate them by having these kind of
squashed cartoony forms.
>>Daniel: Large heads.
>>Dan: Exactly.
So that's, and this has just stayed now and
become part of the art form even though we
don't need it anymore.
>>Ian: I'm not gonna argue with that, but
you can't explain the bare midriff.
You just can't.
[Dan laughs]
>>Dan: I thought it would be interesting because
his dad, also, walks around in a fairly shirtless
way.
And I thought it was to make him be more childlike,
is his dad has like, the 12-pack going.
And he has like this, the, yeah.
I don't know.
>>Daniel: I love how there's a thousand other
elements of this game we could be reviewing,
but we're looking at the bare midriff and
the shirtless dad.
>>Dan: We are following Ian's interests, here.
So, in any case, so things to note in this
game.
One is the back key, pops up and says quit
game and go to main menu with, again, a system
dialogue We do, once again, have the vestigial
menu key.
We have the zoom in key.
It's always fun to actually push this and
see what happened.
Does the game die?
>>Daniel: It's a surprise in every different
game.
>>Dan: I suspect this game is just gonna be
massively unhappy now that we've done this.
But we'll see.
It's always interesting.
So, this is what the game would look like
if you're running it on like, an ancient device
by the way.
Actually, let's do back.
I don't want to do a new game.
Let's do continue.
So, and again, a lot of people say, "Well,
how does pixel art scale?"
And we can't possibly do a game with, that
supports different screens on Android because
pixel art doesn't scale.
It just looks terrible when it has to go down
to a lower resolution, especially this style
of art.
This is the one people complain about the
most because it's got outlines on it.
To be honest, this is totally playable.
Like, I would not be embarrassed at all on
a device with this low resolution having to
actually have this style of art.
So, this is just a note out to you game developers.
It's not nearly as bad as you think.
I just died.
So, I'm gonna quit the game now that I've
died.
Extreme action RPG.
And that's actually the way the game monetizes,
is you actually, you can buy things that allow
you to resurrect yourself.
So, the game is focused on death because death
is how they make money.
At least one of the ways they make money within
the game.
There's also some advertising.
>>Daniel: Maybe that's why the potions are
so hard to get to.
>>Dan: It's possible.
I was curious.
I don't like to be the one who's being the
one mounting conspiracy theories, but that's
certainly a possibility that I considered.
So, yeah.
From a perspective of the game, having that
menu key just doesn't really help them, but
it does actually allow us to talk about something
which I think is fun which is exactly how
a game does support multiple screen styles,
multiple screen resolutions.
And as you can see, it's really not that bad,
even for a game that's as high resolution
as this to actually scale down to incredibly
low resolution.
When we're zooming in there, we were going
down to like, original G1 resolutions.
>>Daniel: Yeah.
>>Dan: But if you want to avoid having that
in your game, it's actually quite easy.
You simply have to make sure that you have
the manifest saying that you support all screens
and that your targeting a recent version of
the SDK.
So, it's, get that out of your game.
Your game doesn't need it.
The game looks beautiful without it.
And don't give a user a reason to push that
button and crash your game.
It's just not worth it.
And the game, by the way, doesn't have to
crash.
That's just the game not handling the re-size
message appropriately.
So, I wanted to take a brief mention.
We did have a couple of other games that were
nominated.
And I know that this was a very narrow nomination
pool here.
We had Parallel Mafia, which really is not
fitting to Asian RPG models.
It does have some artwork that's, I would
say, reminiscent of this, but it really falls
into a totally different category of game.
So, sorry to say, we're not looking at it.
The same thing with My Kingdom for a Princess,
is that what it is I believe it's called.
>>Daniel: Yeah.
>>Dan: We're looking for the prince.
>>Daniel: My Kingdom for, it's a long title.
>>Dan: It's a long title, for the Princess.
>>Daniel: My Kingdom for the Princess Three.
>>Dan: Yes.
And which also falls into that category.
Now, I will say that I did try to look at
this game.
I spent a long time trying to get it download.
And you can see we're on the download screen
now.
And as you see there, it thought it downloaded
a little part of it and then went back and
it failed.
And it's re-downloading again.
The game might be really beautiful.
It certainly, this title screen is gorgeous.
The developers, this is a very, very popular
developer with a lot of popular titles.
So, we'd love to have a look at it, but if
a download does not properly resume, and this
one does not seem to--at least in the three
times that I've had it fail--it has restarted
completely.
That's gonna keep people from playing your
game.
And so, it's something, it's a shame to spend
the thousands of hours in developing a game
title like this only to not have a method
of getting the game to the user.
Now, the other thing, of course I would say,
is that because this is on Google Play, we
really should be using APK expansion files
to deliver the other content.
That way, Google Play will automatically deliver
the content to the device for you and you
don't have to worry about having this downloader.
Now, if you do have content that you're trying
to split across different screen resolutions,
there's a limited amount of that that can
be done using the APK, multiple APK facility
within Google Play.
And, but in general, I think the vast majority
of these games it's not necessary to even
do that.
I think that we're at a point now with modern
hardware, with scaling pixel art looks pretty
good even.
>>Daniel: Yeah.
>>Dan: So just wanna do a brief mention of
those two, why we're not having them on the
show.
But it's always important to me that we, that
things get delivered in a way that's good
for the user.
I will say one nice thing about My Kingdom
for the Princess is that it does not have
the vestigial zoom control, although it does
have the vestigial menu key.
>>Daniel: I also wanna say that I did get
a chance to play Parallel Mafia and it is
a very entertaining game, but maybe we can
cover it in a different show where we cover
miscellaneous games.
It's more of a mash-up type of game.
It's like a MMO combined with a little bit
of RPG with geographical and regional elements
to it, too.
So--.
>>Ian: When I looked at Parallel Mafia, I
really felt like it was representative of
what I think is a new genre of games that
I think we're calling location-based games.
So for instance, Red Robot Labs has a game
called Life is Crime.
It's very similar.
There's a couple other games out there that
are like this where you're basically playing
on a real map.
So it might be actually really cool to do
a show just around location-based games.
It's a pretty new genre though.
I don't know if we'll have enough titles to
look at.
>>Dan: Yeah, I think that's a good, could
be a great idea.
And I mean, I certainly wanna see more innovation
in the mobile game space.
I think one of the unique things about being
on these mobile platforms is that we carry
them around with us.
And so, that does open up a whole bunch of
new gaming.
Plus, potentials.
Plus, there is a lot of opportunity for promoting
local businesses within a game and monetization
as well.
So, I think it's a really interesting category
both in terms of game play as well as in terms
of finding new ways of monetizing games.
So, I think that's, we're gonna have a short
show today.
I don't know if there's anything else we wanna
say.
We do, of course, always value your input
on our moderator page.
So, please continue to nominate games for
our next few weeks.
We do have a few more weeks lined up.
And we will continue to hopefully be here.
>>Daniel: Yes.
We'll definitely be here.
Do we know what's down for next week?
No, but--.
>>Dan: Hold on.
>>Ian: No, no.
We do.
That's right, folks.
We are having a short show today.
Our show is only going three minutes overtime.
And before we leave, yes, we do have a show
next week.
We do have a topic for it.
It escapes me at the moment what it is.
>>Dan: I do know the week after next week,
we're gonna be targeting NFL apps.
>>Ian: That's right.
Week after next it's all about football.
And not Reto's kind of football.
>>Dan: No, no.
>>Ian: Our kind of football.
>>Daniel: The real kind of football.
>>Dan: The next week we have brain and puzzle.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Dan: Right, soccer.
>>Ian: And before we leave, let's just do--.
>>Dan: Brain and puzzle games.
>>Ian: Ah, brain and puzzle.
Yeah, actually brain and puzzle games, we
have this request from a viewer that wanted
to nominate their brain and puzzle game.
I think that it's a great genre and I'm really,
really excited to take a look at that.
I will be back here next week.
I sat out this show doing the producer thing
because I am, if nothing, not an Asian RPG
fan.
But before--.
>>Dan: So, are you saying that Daniel Pham
is our Asian correspondent?
>>Ian: Yeah, he's our token Asian.
That's right.
>>Daniel: Thanks, guys.
>>Ian: Yeah.
Right.
Any VPI or M RPGs, it's just [ muttering ].
>>Daniel: You guys can guess.
You guys can guess.
>>Ian: All right.
Anyway.
>>Daniel: Moderator page.
You guys can Google.
>>Dan: What kind of Asian do you think Daniel
Pham is?
>>Daniel: Yes, what kind of Asian do you think
I am?
>>Ian: That's right.
And also, I just wanna make sure that everybody
holds up their beer before we leave, yeah.
How much has Dan drunk?
>>Dan: Not very much.
>>Ian: Hard to tell in this, but I think I've
got about a quarter bottle left.
So, I'm not doing too well.
>>Daniel: Yeah.
>>Ian: Dan you.
>>Dan: Well, we're both Dan, so it works out.
I think Daniel--.
>>Ian: He's not broken until he loses the
deposit on his apartment.
>>Dan: [laughs] So the, yeah.
>>Ian: Guys, thanks for tuning in.
Thanks a lot for being on the livestream.
By the way, I do have to mention, so there's
some great comments right at the end of the
livestream.
First, I think Dan Galpin should be drinking
more beer.
That's a great.
Oh, I love that comment.
The other ones are, it would be great to review
something like the old school Elite.
Oh, my God.
I have to tell you.
That is so true.
Elite was my favorite game ever.
>>Dan: Did you leave that comment, Ian?
That sounds like a comment from you.
>>Daniel: Someone else left that comment.
I think Ian created a new account and signed
in as himself just to post that comment.
>>Dan: Exactly.
>>Ian: If I was gonna create an account, it
would not be named Dennis P. Boost.
No offense to the Dennis P. Boosts of this
world, but this wouldn't be my first choice.
>>Dan: There you go.
>>Ian: I would probably go for, I don't know--.
>>Dan: Dennis Q. Boost.
>>Ian: Probably.
Anyway, so yeah.
Elite and Rogue, actually, were the two suggestions.
I think those are both great suggestions.
>>Dan: Yeah.
Rogue, it's interesting 'cause Rogue, I think
that almost all of these RPGs that we looked
at today actually do, are descendants of Rogue
to some degree or another.
Actually, if you play Dungeon Hunter Three
from Gameloft, it pretty much is Rogue with
updated graphics and a couple of additional
elements.
But yeah.
I think that there's certainly, I wanna see
more games that are like Elite.
I'd like to see the original Elite come back
in some super awesome form.
I was a huge fan of the--.
>>Ian: The original Elite come back as a mobile
title.
And not that, OK.
All props to the original Elite authors, but
when you brought it to PC and called it Frontier,
it was a mistake.
You did not do well with that.
There were issues there.
>>Dan: I was a huge fan of the Wing Commander
games.
I was a huge fan of Fighter.
>>Daniel: Yeah, me too, actually.
>>Ian: Privateer Two, one of the best games
ever made.
And after that, Frontier.
>>Dan: Absolutely.
And I actually, I was a huge fan of Star Flight
as well, in that series of games, which all
owe that their legacy to Elite.
So, it would be great to see that.
There's a, I also wanna, as far as early games
that I wanna see, I very much wanna see Archon
come to Androids.
>>Ian: Hell yes.
>>Dan: So, it's React Games, you have the
license.
Bring it on, all right?
And that's pretty much it, I think, for us
on the Friday Review of Games.
Again, come back.
Keep nominating brain and puzzle games for
us to look at next week.
I, as always, am Dan Galpin.
With me is Daniel Pham.
And, of course, we have Reto, who is currently
running our technical deck here.
And we have Ian on producer.
So, thank you all.
>>Daniel: Thank you, guys.
We'll see you next week.
>>Dan: And cheers.
>>Daniel: Cheers.